on this episode of Imagine a world
I think World building did turn out to
be really useful thinking creatively
about some kind of ambitious things we
could do and depicting them in a way
that makes them visceral and makes them
feel real and possible that is really
useful for sort of bringing people's
thinking up and letting them imagine and
letting them believe they can build
something big and complicated and new
the question is what should we build
welcome to imagine a world a mini series
from the future of Life Institute this
podcast is based on a contest we ran to
gather ideas from around the world about
what a more positive future might look
like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as f-aligned or positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagine a world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason
in this episode we'll be speaking with
Mako yes whose World which is called to
light was the first place winner of
fli's World building contest
what stood out about mako's world was
its imaginative storytelling with richly
interwoven narrative threads and high
concept sci-fi inventions it undergoes
one of the most complete Transformations
we've seen in our entries there are
immortality drugs augmentations that
merge humans with machines and colonies
orbiting the Sun all interlaced with
care and attention towards AI safety
these Fantastical Transformations aren't
without their growing pains and not
everyone in this world Embraces them at
first
some resist even the life-saving miracle
pills and choose to live in the lower
Tech communities Closer To Nature
these holdouts are not pressured to
accept enhancement Technologies but any
who change their minds are welcomed by
those who have
as Mako puts it everyone who would like
to is going to make it
Our Guest today is the sole author of
this world
he lives in Auckland New Zealand and
calls himself a stray philosopher
designer
one of Marco's passions is fostering
media that moves us to protect
Humanity's future which he explores by
designing civically robust digital
communities and positive some games
about brokering peace
his creativity and pragmatic optimism
made his entry a powerful fit for the
contest and I'm pleased to have him here
with me to discuss his work today
it's great to have you here with us
first of all can you say a little bit
about what you mean when you call
yourself a stray philosopher designer
um
I've never thought about this before
well I'm curious if you could start out
with what what your educational
background is and kind of what you've
been up to in the years since yeah uh so
I think the first subject I really
connected with academically was
programming and explaining things to
computers was
how I experienced it and what was
interesting about it to me
because computers don't really know
anything so if you can explain something
to a computer then you you really must
understand it
and I think that turns out to be a
really good basis for analytic
philosophy
so I went into a degree about a logic
and computation and Linguistics and a
bit of computer science
gotcha
What attracted you to try to enter the
competition so I think it was mainly
seeing other people talk about how hard
it was or how impossible it was to meet
the required specs and they had a really
good point
but there were holes in it and I
realized I could probably pass through
those holes and and make something that
did The Impossible and that's always
very exciting when you find a concept
through that route you you know it's
going to end up producing something good
you mean like that it's so highly
constrained yeah yeah like
it it will be surprising to people the
thing that you find because yeah they
clearly had this very strong expectation
that there wouldn't be a thing that
could do that yeah there it is
um I like that that's the challenge that
motivated you uh yeah a really good
problem formulation is like most of the
way to getting to a really useful
solution yeah
it sounds like part of the the match
between what the problem that was posed
in your skills was also kind of this
positive bent to it like I noticed in
your work you're really interested in
you know positive some games and trying
to get societies of people to interact
in really effective ways you have this
kind of optimistic aim to a lot of your
work and that's really at the heart of
the fli project did that kind of
resonate with you I think one of the
things you learned from programming is
you learn a joy of making things so of
course the things you want to make are
usually good
so it's kind of being asked to to make a
solution to this enormous problem that
I've been aware of for a bit and yeah of
course I'm going to be interested in
that right
yes I'm curious what were your biggest
sources of inspiration when creating
this world
I I probably should mention Tara ignota
which is a sort of semi-utopian
fiction series written by a historian
and it's one of the few
series that are you know trying to
depict a positive future interesting and
so that I think that prepared me pretty
well to like look at a future where
everything goes well and still sort of
find where the tensions are and
um where where the cruxes were and where
it could have gone wrong and focus on
those and that's where the story is yeah
so that was useful and I there are a few
things from again like it's ambiguous as
to whether this was an inspiration but
there are a few things from Terry ignota
that sort of made it in and one was the
the doves that was like that was
basically in Tara ignota there were
these the drones that are in the shapes
of Dubs yeah yeah carrying around
supplies of Peace interesting but like
when I decided to put that in Delight uh
it felt like there was no alternative
like I didn't think I was taking it from
somewhere else it's just like what
should these drones look like well doves
like they're the most harmless animal
yeah it just seemed like it was there
was only one way to do it yeah that's
funny
foreign
by 2045 maco's world has undergone a
drastic transformation there is an AI
designed Miracle pill called bright Moss
that greatly extends lifespan and
eradicates most human diseases
sachets of this life-saving medicine are
distributed by dove-shaped drones as he
just mentioned there's also a kind of
mind uploading which lets anyone become
whatever they wish live indefinitely and
gain augmented intelligence the
distribution of wealth is almost
perfectly even with every human assigned
a share of all resources
and some people even move into space
building massive structures around the
Sun where they practice esoteric arts in
pursuit of a more perfect piece Mako put
a lot of thought into how these
Technologies are received by different
elements of society and how this impacts
their relationships over time
I wanted to take a few minutes to get
clear on how each of these technological
facets of this world actually looked
also I thought it'd be nice to talk
about some of the things that you
imagined for our future that are in this
positive direction
you have a lot of very Fantastical kind
of Innovations and transformative events
that happen to humanity and I thought
maybe we could explore some of them
so the first one is bright Moss which is
this kind of cure-all drug that gets rid
of a lot of human diseases and can
extend lifespan I heard you say that
it's partly named
um to allude to the fact that it's a
living substance that stays in you so
are you imagining it as some kind of
symbiotic living drug
yeah I it's often very useful for a name
to address the most
hostile stories that are going to be
told about the things so I think in
order to do the things that a general
life extension drug will need to do it's
it's going to be very sophisticated it's
going to basically need to be alive in
itself I mean in reality life extension
treatments are probably going to involve
more than one medicine but if you have
to focus it all down to a single
medicine then yeah that's going to be
difficult so it's going to end up having
this strange alien quality and and
people are gonna analyze it and find out
about that and a lot of people are going
to be scared by that if you need to go
that route so yeah I tried to find a
name that would sort of address that and
make that less scary for people so that
fewer people would um
yeah we should get into the fact that
the biggest problem that exists in this
world after uh solving the alignment
problem this this sort of comes after
that is that people can still choose to
not take the treatments and to keep
aging and to die and that's kind of a
tragedy every single person who's lost
is a bit of a tragedy the entire future
goes on without them
so most of what happens after that point
is focusing on sort of reaching those
people and convincing them to stay on
board with the future
I like how you have in the name there's
this Moss piece which is you know mosses
as you mentioned are often kind of
medicinal in human history and obviously
bright Moss just feels friendly and on
the other side you have the people
you're talking about who are a bit
hesitant to take these kinds of drugs or
change themselves in a way they think is
not possible to undo and they call it
Apophis which I think is a reference to
some kind of flesh-eating bacteria is
that right yeah you have to accept that
some people will make their own names
for things yeah
it's interesting that your world has has
built in so thoughtfully people who
don't see it as a Utopia as some kind of
positive thing to Aspire to
and so while you've while you've taken
on this challenge of writing a positive
future that we can all aspire to on some
level there are still those within it
who don't see it as a positive future
what do you what do you think about what
should be done with them should they all
be convinced as you're saying or should
there be space Mage for people who don't
want to live in that way
I think for it to be a positive future
there has to be space but at the same
time of course we we don't want those
people to die we we don't want those
people to make this terrible choice we
want to reach them if we can we want to
convince them so that ends up being the
place that we focus because that's
that's where the problems in the world
still exist
yeah I'm not totally sure about the
writing technique of focusing on the
drama focusing on the conflict are you
saying that to to kind of put this drama
and conflict in his in its place as a
smaller feature of a larger world that's
mostly aligned right it was small yeah
yeah yeah I never really communicated
that probably very very few people are
living this way
brightness not only extends lifespan but
also People's Health span right the
amount of healthy years that they have
I think that would make it more widely
accepted
but I'd still suspect that more people
than you might think would be hesitant
to extend their lives there are a lot of
factors that could play into that
hesitancy like mental health concerns
religious or philosophical
considerations
do you personally feel that living
longer is sort of just a general good or
do you have any hesitations about that
they're definitely causes for concern
but yeah sure on that it's good I mean
the longer I live the more I get the
sense there's there's a richness to life
or you use you get used to it you you
get to like it more as you go further in
that you you get better at it from more
connections
um you get better at Living
interesting
another transformative technology in
your world is tempering which makes
people live indefinitely grants them
these incredible mental Powers but
you're a little vager about what this
process actually involves
so as people become tempered what
happens to them like do you have some
specific process in mind or is this kind
of a stand-in for some kind of
transhumanist or post-human
transformation
yeah I have no concrete ideas
um because I don't think that's
something we could know from from here
back here uh it's basically mind
uploading the thing that we currently
call mind uploading which is just
essentially it's supposed to be
referring to taking a human mind
um all their behaviors their personality
their memories and transitioning it to a
sort of stronger and more flexible form
and I think calling that uploading is a
bit confused because uploading is when
you send something through a wire into a
computer and
uh the things we call computers today
couldn't really run a human brain
maybe they could run some approximate
form of it but I think when we do this
for real hopefully we will we'll
probably find another name for it
another thing that features in your
world is that by 2045 you have an almost
totally even distribution of wealth
which is quite an accomplishment it
seems that this is partly because of
this distribution of what you call
Cosmic endowment chairs so the
allocation of some portion of kind of
all observable or accessible resources
to each human
um can you say more about how that works
that is a tricky topic because we don't
know and we need to figure it out very
soon
um so I won't claim to know exactly how
that's going to work but roughly
speaking it's supposed to
given equal portion of the future
resources of humanity to every human
a lot of the worlds we received featured
some form of universal basic income but
yours has really this more hard reset
where everyone suddenly put on equal
footing
can you say something about how you go
about ensuring that that kind of wealth
equality lasts
so one thing I can say is I think
there's hope that if you
start over the wealth distribution from
scratch and then give everyone access to
much better sort of financial advisors
essentially
just the best possible financial
advisors make everyone into a financial
advisor you're going to end up with a
much more fair World probably
indefinitely it will probably stay Fair
yeah so you're Distributing not only
wealth but also knowledge to manage the
wealth yeah
um so it's quite possible that that will
be enough you won't really need any
ongoing redistribution but
there are a lot of philosophical reasons
to to think that we might need ongoing
redistribution it's it's still unclear
yeah so this is something we're working
on just
[Music]
while the peaceful flourishing end state
of maco's world is deeply optimistic
he's also very conscious of the
challenges facing Humanity along the way
he sees a strong need for Global
collaboration and investment to avoid
catastrophe as Humanity develops more
and more powerful Technologies
he's particularly concerned with the
risks presented by artificial
intelligence systems as they begin to
surpass us
an AIS is that's more capable than a
human at all tasks not just playing
chess or driving a car is what we call
an artificial general intelligence
abbreviated AGI
ensuring that such a system actually
behaves as we intend and Faithfully
pursues goals that are beneficial rather
than harmful to humans is an enormous
challenge that we don't yet know how to
solve
micro proposes that we could build safe
agis through radical transparency
he imagines tests that could reveal the
true intentions and expectations of AI
systems before they're released into the
world
picture a research team reporting that a
new AI system expects humans will go
extinct within 50 years of its public
release
Franco hopes that the jolt of fear from
such a finding could catalyze a truly
Global Alliance for developing safe AI
he imagines an international network of
the best human thinkers working together
in highly secured virtual spaces to
create a safe AGI
and he imagines us succeeding so that
Beyond these dangerous years of
development a new chapter of human
history begins to unfold
let's dig deeper into how Mako sees this
journey playing out
what are some other major challenges
that you chose to explore when you are
working on your world
so I guess the core problem that I'm
taking on is uh
I don't know if this position has a name
because the literature that
you can find it most easily and just
sort of assumes that it's it's the truth
and so they don't really name it
um other people disagree I guess I will
name it uh
the naturalness of the agency
uh the claim that agency or rationality
or power-seeking behavior is a very
natural sort of mathematical structure
or natural tendency that machine
learning systems are going to end up
taking on
uh pretty abruptly at some point so it's
the assumption that if we keep training
more and more powerful machine learning
systems one day we're gonna suddenly
arrive at something that is sort of
making its own decisions and setting its
own strategies
going out into the world and acting on
its own
uh and that's a very dangerous situation
because you can no longer really turn it
off
and if you messed it up and the issue is
we tend to mess everything up the first
time we try it
in this case you don't get to try again
it's out it's alive it's standing on its
own feet
and it's stronger than you
so I wanted to take on that problem if
if that is what machine learning and or
mathematics or whatever is like if it
tends to as we call it film
uh what is that word
yeah I don't think it's an acronym just
like the sound of a blowtorch being lit
I think I think it was taken from like a
a panel from a comic or something
it's onomatopoeia yeah yeah okay yeah
one day you'll you'll train a machine
Learning System and it'll make that
sound and at that point you need to get
out of the room immediately
so yeah I have seen this assumption I
think in in a lot of approaches to
thinking about how AI will develop I
haven't really fully understood why all
of these things are assumed to come
together like I get the idea of a system
becoming so powerful or so complex that
it develops its own agency and starts
seeking its own goals and also the idea
that it could be smarter than us and
also the idea that it could become more
powerful than us but couldn't these
happen separately like what if a system
became sort of rational but then was
still stuck in the chassis chassis that
it was in that that would be a good
outcome because then we could use it to
make something that we can
um guarantee is human aligned and then
we can release that out into the world
um yeah I mean if we can make a system
that's way smarter than humans but also
not power seeking then we can use that
to um to do it properly to make sure
we've definitely gotten it right
I think we should probably take a step
back and talk a little bit about the
alignment problem and what that means
because we're kind of using words
associated with it without having really
said what it is so in at the broadest
level my understanding is that it's just
the idea that we need to get these
systems to stay in line with our goals
and what we actually intend for them to
carry out in the world so we don't want
them to behave like an evil Genie and
try to twist our intentions and do
something unexpected and damaging when
we've put in something that we think is
going to be benign right which is what
happens if you uh if you try to write
down exactly what you want them to do
and then tell them to do that you're
probably going to get it wrong and it's
going to come out Twisted yeah so
instead what we want to do is we want to
set them up so that they they learn on
their own what it is that humans value
yeah so I would I would describe the
alignment problem as the problem of
uh getting powerful machine Learning
Systems to uh want for the world the
same things that we want for the world
yeah so that's kind of that's one end of
the alignment problem and my
understanding which is given a goal how
do you get it to match that goal or how
do you ensure that this powerful agent
that you've made is going to actually be
pursuing that same goal but there's sort
of the other end of it which is maybe
more philosophical which is what goal
should we be feeding into this device
and you've been saying kind of what
Humanity wants but how do we determine
what goal we'll sort of collectively fit
all of our wills and and maybe even I
would say again since I'm thinking about
animals the will of other creatures in
the world Maybe
hopefully we we won't have to be very
specific about it and we'll just be able
to say okay you see these these
creatures out here these humans these
animals
figure out what they want you figure it
out and then do that
so sort of acting in a sort of more
abstract way defining it in a more
abstract way
interesting
what happens if those wants conflict
yeah that's a really interesting
question that's something I'm studying a
lot in part for game design reasons it's
it's sort of the question of Cooperative
bargaining Theory
which is the mathematical study of how
to reach agreements when people want
different things and I think it's really
beautiful stuff and more people should
know about it so I've been trying to
make games about it
and also it turns out that these games
are going to be really rich like once
you remove the zero-sum quality of that
most board games have and you allow
people to
make deals make agreements and find
mutually beneficial outcomes I think the
games often get a lot more rich
yeah so for those who don't know a
zero-sum game is one where anytime
someone gains something someone else is
losing it so the sum is zero right like
you can't just create value you have to
kind of steal it from the common pool
basically in the end in these types of
games typically there can only be one
winner and if you win that means
everyone else loses so in a non-zero-sum
game you can have these situations where
everyone actually benefits by
collaborating
you might end up with everyone winning
or everyone losing and these changes
move us away from the more typical
self-interested competitive models of
zero-sum games
I saw you're calling these new non-zero
sum or positive sum games peace Wagers
is that a term you're using to describe
all games that aren't Zero Sum in that
way I'm calling them peace Wagers yeah
I'm I can't I've lost my precise
definition of what they are because it
turns out that semi-cooperative games
already exist and I I think they're a
subset of that but I'm not sure exactly
which yeah I look forward to seeing more
about that I saw there's some on your
website
macopool.org is that right there's not a
lot of information there yet yeah
there's a little description of what
you're up to yeah yeah that that will be
enough for people to be able to tell
whether they they want to get on board
and help out and make some of these
interesting
another tool in your world's Arsenal for
building consensus is the ability to
identify people's deepest wishes
through some feat of Technology people
in your world can basically print out a
clear description of their core desires
do you have anything to say about how
that could impact people's relationships
or society as a whole like if we really
had a way to truly know our own or each
other's deepest desires and motivations
what would that do
that could go a lot of interesting ways
because we really I think we have no
idea what we actually want I don't think
I don't think humans evolved to be good
at telling people what they really want
but
um
and there's a book about that
um written by
uh
I sometimes describe him as a Xeno
Economist because he's sort of good at
standing outside of our society he's a
bit of an alien
um also if you wanted someone to analyze
economies constructed by aliens he would
he would be the only person you could go
to Robin Hansen and you wrote this book
elephants in the brain which
it's it's sort of a rigorous approach to
um
the younging concept of the Shadow the
idea that we have these hidden desires
and then they sort of know what they're
doing and we don't know what they're
doing we're just an outward
representative who says what people want
to hear
and he sort of studies the extent to
which that's true and uh I would
recommend that book so I think it's
going to turn out it's the answer is
going to surprise us it may turn out to
be Hedonism but
none of my homies are into hedonism
um that's a great sentence but yeah it
might turn out that actually we are we
just pretend not to be because we want
to seem sophisticated and and gigantic
so you could like turn on this device
and it's like my wife I really want to
know your deepest desire and she's like
cake yeah and they're like okay it would
be really unfortunate so much for the
mystery of our love
yeah all of your relationships were just
interaction on your desire for cake just
an advanced strategy
why did you marry a baker
[Music]
this brings me back to my other really
higher level question about
whose morality is being applied here
like what is a Sinister thought like
what if to one Society or culture a
certain thought is is wonderful and
freeing into another one is Sinister and
dangerous
so this would come down to Cooperative
bargaining how do you reconcile
conflicting desires of different
cultures
and yeah really that's a realm of theory
that we need to develop a lot more as
quickly as we possibly can so it
definitely makes sense to talk about an
individual's desire and the question is
when we have more than one desire how do
we reconcile those into a sort of
compromised desire that pursues them
both as well as possible
uh yeah that's a question we're deeply
interested in and there's work to be
done there
well all that gets to this higher level
question of how we can collaborate to
decide on what we want AI systems to do
for us but there's also this more
technical end of alignment which is just
about getting a system to pursue a goal
reliably
so like once you've decided what you
want the system to do how can you be
sure it'll actually do that
one thing that you came up with to that
end is this idea of somehow peering into
these systems and figuring out what they
truly expect or plan to do so in
particular you wanted to look for
indicators that they might do something
really dangerous or damaging for
Humanity and you call the safety testing
process demon cadding which I think is
short for demonstrating a catastrophic
trajectory
can you tell us about how that could
work
so I I think in practice that's going to
end up being the same project as uh
inspectability or explainability
which is you have this very complex and
quite opaque machine Learning System
and you want to figure out what's going
on inside it what does it really do and
what will it do when we release it out
into the world
um out of out of testing environments
and out of the environments we've seen
it in before
and
that's a big project it will probably
sort of add up to democrating yes I'll
Define democratic basically I propose
preparing in advance to get really
really good at analyzing a things
knowledge format or finding where the
knowledge is and decoding the knowledge
representation format I think if we can
do that then we have a sort of way of
asking it questions that it doesn't know
it's being asked so that it sort of has
to answer them truthfully in the same
way that it would answer questions it's
asking of itself
this is basically to me it sounds like a
form of mind reading if we take it to be
a real agent you're kind of trying to
dig into its subconscious if you will to
figure out what it truly intends or
believes
yeah yeah so I I guess I would translate
digging into the subconscious as like
bypassing the the part that's designed
to communicate with external agents
which might turn out to be very
difficult if people keep trying to build
AI on large language models which are
sort of
they know how to lie before they know
how to
care what the truth is in a sense
interesting
so what would incentivize researchers to
try to find these problems in their AI
systems I mean it's hard work to try to
figure out if there are any you know
Sinister thoughts lurking
how how can we try to encourage them to
do that and see finding them is a good
thing one thing worth noting is that
they already have a very large incentive
and that none of them want to be
dehabitated by a
misaligned AI themselves
in a way no one has an incentive to take
risks on this but I I realize sometimes
that doesn't really translate into the
decisions that an organization makes
so yeah I'm not sure
um vast amounts of Public Funding for
uh closely integrated alignment programs
and every AI research organization that
would be nice
yeah
so you describe something like that
coming about in your world you call it
acai awsai which stands for the Allied
world for strong artificial intelligence
and we should say for those who aren't
familiar with the term strong artificial
intelligence is this kind of
intelligence that is it's a system that
is more powerful more successful at all
tasks than a human not just like playing
chess or driving a car it's kind of
universally better than us
um and so this is a Global Alliance
right to try to pursue the successful
creation of this kind of thing
it would be very good to have that and I
I guess most of the story is sort of
Reckoning with the fact that building
that is very difficult and we probably
couldn't do it yet and asking okay what
would need to happen in order for the
world to realize that this is a very
dire situation that we're in and get to
the point where we could build
um a truly global Allied worlds for uh
alignment
yeah creating that truly Global Alliance
seemed like a really pivotal success for
your world
even with that strong fear motivator I
think it would be very difficult today
to coordinate that scale of
collaboration
in your submission you imagined multiple
elements that facilitate this and one
factor I really appreciated was the
impact of VR
which is also something I'm personally
interested in and in your world it
really seems to bring people together
you know as you say if we were a better
species text would be enough
but there's really something
transformative about inhabiting the same
space as somebody
and so VR becomes really massive in your
world you say that in 2037 the average
user spends almost 90 percent of their
waking hours in VR we should say this is
with kind of regular eyeglasses sized VR
headsets so it's not like you have a big
Oculus on your head all day long right
yeah it sounds very extreme that it's
not it's just wearing glasses basically
yeah sure but it's it's still a really
big transformation where we spend our
time right and you point out how this
decentralizes delocalizes people's
interactions it makes Global
interactions so much easier and really
lowers the barrier for collaboration
can you say a bit more about how this
impacts people's experiences in your
world
yeah I'm really hoping it leads to a lot
more
cross-organization collaboration
it's conceivable that keeping
organizations separate might actually
become quite difficult under these
conditions because
a person can meet a person outside of
the organization just as easily as they
can meet someone inside
so yeah under that situation how do you
have an arms race I don't know maybe
it's impossible maybe we'll be safe at
that point once everyone's sort of
essentially in the same room all of the
time
right
dystopian stories of the future are all
too common especially when powerful
artificial intelligences and robots come
into the mix even if these portrayals
represent real risks we feel that risk
communication is at its most powerful
when it's paired with hope
part of the goal of this contest was to
steer our Collective image of the future
towards something more positive but
without ending up in an unrealistic
Utopia either
we hope that this can generate some real
insights into how we might navigate
towards a future Worth Fighting For
let's hear how Mako sees his work in
relation to other cultural portrayals of
the future
so we wanted to spend a bit of time
talking about
how cultural representations of some of
the issues you explore in your world are
kind of impacting the way people think
about these problems and how those could
be challenged
so one example of that is the issue of
alignment and often we see the alignment
problem in its kind of dystopian sci-fi
as having gone wrong in a way such that
AI becomes sentient and you know has
like a robot army and turns back against
us like in The Matrix that doesn't
really seem to be what AI safety
researchers are actually worried about
because there are so many different ways
that misalignments can occur that don't
involve that kind of like physical agent
battle like robot army deal
do you feel that that is something that
we culturally overestimate
oh yeah
it's never going to get to the point
where there are two armies and one of
them belongs to humans and the other
belongs to AIS it ends for humans a lot
sooner than that humans can get diseases
that's one of our big weaknesses and
that sort of does not look like an army
and
it's very difficult to fight it and the
main way you fight it is by receding
into sealed bunkers uh
violence from a super intelligent AI
would would not look like an army I
would say that's true
one thing that your your world does
include is
I think there's this major fear that the
AI will be malicious or as you were
saying have like Sinister thoughts and
I'm curious about
possible Futures where AI isn't
necessarily malicious but just
misaligned in a way that is deeply
problematic
do you have any feeling for how much
you're actually worried about like a
mean AI versus a problematically badly
aligned AI That's not mean if that makes
sense
I don't really think about mean or
vindictive or um punitive AIS or
threatening threatening AIS very much
yeah I mean most of the risks we're
concerned about is just you get a system
that wants to do something that is not
really compatible with the continuation
of humanity and the issue is there are
many goals that could lead to that like
if it just
sort of
um I can probably think of a plausible
one we can use the example of a I think
it's Nick Bostrom who has the paper clip
machine right this machine that just
wants to create paper clips out of
everything and this doesn't sound too
bad until it starts ripping you apart to
make more paper clips from the iron in
your blood yeah yeah because eventually
yeah that becomes a profitable yeah and
the iron in the sun and the iron and the
other stars which you needed to survive
yeah so it's essentially
I'm more worried about uh dehabitation
the same way that Humanity dehabitates
other species if you have a much more
powerful industrial system that doesn't
care about the Human Habitat then it
will eventually get to the level of
power where has a reason to turn it into
something else and then we won't have it
and then we'll die
yeah interesting are there examples of
media where this is the case that you
can think of where an AI doesn't
necessarily want to destroy us but has
other kind of maybe benign seeming goals
that end up being a big problem for us
no benign seeming no I don't I don't
know if I've seen that that would be
really interesting
yeah I mean it's interesting how it
might just be a feature of you know the
stories that are easiest to tell because
it makes sense to have
a villain in the story that actively is
trying to do something that's opposed to
our interests as humans
and it's a little bit harder to tell a
story where the villain just doesn't
really care about you or maybe know
about or understand you
you know I think the distinction is
you can tell the story for longer if the
humans have a fighting chance and they
exchange a lot of blows back and forth
for a long time
in the situations where the the system
is just kind of indifferent to humans
and and doesn't just sort of destroys
them incidentally that's that's a
situation where yeah it's way more
powerful than us there's not much we can
do
yeah so you don't get a long story
[Music]
it's interesting that the outcomes
you're describing there are kind of
zero-sum stories whether the AI or
Humanity wins the other loses maybe
there's a parallel to the board game
World here where exploring positive some
systems can lead to more interesting
narratives like one thing I found really
interesting about the resolution of your
world is the way that the AI itself kind
of disappeared or was dissolved into and
became one with what became of humanity
I think there's often this idea that
like you were saying before there's like
an army there's two sides there's humans
in the AIS but if we assume that there's
a real solution to this alignment
problem and the goals of the system are
truly reflecting the goals of humanity
somehow as a whole
and it kind of does make sense that we
would become one thing yeah I think
essentially that has to happen
it's also interesting to me to see the
variety of positive Futures people came
up with you know one of one of the
things we asked for in the competition
was a world that we would reasonably
want to live in
and that is really different for
different people you know given their
preferences and cultural background and
Life Experiences
and I think it'll be really interesting
to see
what others who think about a positive
future imagine yeah I found telling a
story that would lead to an outcome
that's agreeable to everyone I found
that really difficult and that ended up
leading to this sort of synthesis of AI
Control and human control and realizing
that there shouldn't really be a
difference you give the AI Control and
if it really has humans interests in
this and it's hard then uh
it hands the control right back
yeah
well in addition to collecting more
interesting and diverse visions of the
future one of the reasons we ran this
contest is to try to show that imagining
positive Futures can help us to address
the problems that are standing in our
way
that's not really something we get from
the probably more common dystopian views
of the future
so the hope I think is that by imagining
things we actually want to work towards
we can get people to be motivated to
carry out the changes we need to get
there
do you think that that's a reasonable
kind of mechanism of action or Pathway
to aim for absolutely yeah
and do you have any media that comes to
mind that you think helps this cause
I don't no I didn't yeah I can't think
of a lot of really helpful utopian
fiction
why do you think that is like why why
are dystopian views so common
I think there's an idea that if you
depict the problem then that will be
more motivating to people I'm not sure
how true that is but enough writers
believe it that that's what you get
it's funny when you put it that way it
makes me think that actually the the
demon cutting in your world is kind of
the ultimate motivating dystopian
fiction right like it's a it's a
prediction by researchers that there
will be this real dystopian future if we
don't get our get ourselves together
yeah interesting
well it's been fun to see how just by
being positive the stories we've
collected have defied so many of the
typical narratives that we're used to
hearing about the future
I'm curious if there are any specific
tropes that you were thinking about when
you were building your world that you
kind of tried to consciously oppose
the Norman media is to depict AI as
arriving very gradually so like you'll
have robots that are roughly human level
slightly below human level and they're
walking around and doing everyday tasks
and
there's not really a reason to believe
it's gonna go that way I mean as as far
as I'm aware it could
but I think traditional science fiction
is way too confident of that I think
it's pretty likely that we're gonna get
to autonomous cars and then like four
years later we're gonna have AGI and
it's it's going to be Way Beyond human
capabilities and there's not really
going to be a long period where we have
robots
hmm
yeah I did notice that in your world it
was kind of funny because you have you
do have this thread where we have
bipedal walking machines that are used
for all kinds of remote manual labor and
such but they don't really feature that
strongly in the concerns of you know the
organizations trying to do safe AI
development it's not like there's this
concern about a robot war which you'd
often see in more traditional sci-fi
stories I feel like they just kind of
withered on the side because they
weren't really the main heart of the
issue yeah the heart of the issue is
when you have something that's better at
making AI than we are
interesting or or it's better at
Logistics or assembling uh security or
it's stuff or it's better at science
yeah or it combines those things
especially it might just turn out to be
very easy to do
yeah you had that whole I forget the
name of it Orion or something oroclan
yeah I I wanted to acknowledge the
possibility that we might end up with
the logistics intelligence that um can't
really do science and and can't do AI
research and doesn't understand itself
particularly well enough to self-improve
its intelligence
yeah because that could still be
dangerous in a kind of fun and
traditional science fiction way because
you have this thing that's protecting
its facilities but it's also kind of
dependent on human technology
and it has these blind spots
yeah so Auto plan is is a system that
kind of seems to do Materials Science
basically and also be able to produce
you know Logistics and construction
Industrial Systems
so that it can actually carry out the
whole stack of hypothesizing and testing
and Manufacturing new materials and
things like that yeah it's totally
conceivable that you could get something
that does that without really much
self-reflection and without any uh
impetus to think about uh intelligence
itself
a sort of science algorithm or science
and Manufacturing algorithm that'd be
really useful and it would generate a
lot of wealth for society
but it's not guaranteed
and it's not guaranteed that if we get
that then that's what we're going to
have for a very long time it might be
that that's quite a brief error and then
we get something that's self-improving
and strategic and then that error is
over and we need to make sure that that
transition out of that era is positive
yeah
I really enjoyed thinking about Aura
plan it was like a little mini story
within your world that explored this
totally different breed of AI that could
develop
you really managed to pack a lot of
overlapping narratives into your
submission there's one other kind of
meta thing that I really appreciated
that you included which is this idea of
the very end of your world where some
people started to believe maybe their
reality was a simulation and that it was
meant to work out some problem and now
that they'd reached the end of solving
their piece there wouldn't be anything
left to simulate and the world would be
shut down
and you kind of tongue-in-cheek point
out that this actually happened you know
in your appendix because you stopped
thinking about the world and so nothing
else happened for them
I really love this idea I'm curious if
you've seen this happen in another piece
of media like was there an inspiration
for this concept or did it just come to
you
probably at some point yeah I mean I
would have seen someone frame the
question
um do characters and stories experience
their own existence and I guess the
related question is when an actor is
performing a character are the things
that they're performing is is that in a
sense being experienced so if they're
performing heartbreak is that creating
suffering on some level yeah
um probably
now that I reflect on it
that's right that doesn't upset too many
people
it really changes the calculus because
you know if peace is destruction then
the people in your world shouldn't
necessarily be pursuing peace and I
could imagine if it kept iterating a bit
more you know maybe things would go
wrong in a way that would keep you
writing the story yeah uh yeah I think
it's it's quite plausible that in
reality we'll be pursuing some really
complicated and difficult form of Peace
where we have to maintain narrative
tension about some some fact of our
society in order to make it worth it to
continue simulating it by whoever would
be yeah because I have done a bit of
work in simulationism and like get the
impression it probably is possible to
reason from what we know about
technological societies as a result of
being one
to make guesses about the kinds of
questions the simulators might be
interested in
and
once we know that then
we can start to reason about what the
rules are
being a stimulants and what the rules of
our simulated possibly simulated reality
would be and then things get really
interesting but I I haven't I haven't
found a reason to talk about that much
publicly
oh yeah
I like your comment about pursuing a
complicated kind of piece that has to
maintain some tensions that reminds me
again of the Matrix where agent Smith I
think says they previously tried a
matrix where everything was perfect but
the humans rejected it and they they
weren't comfortable in that space some
some deep animal part of their brain
just wasn't satisfied with that level of
peace and lack of conflict and so they
had to make you know 90s New York
instead which has plenty of conflict uh
see my my preferred explanation for 90s
Euro because um if I were writing a
version of The Matrix now knowing what I
what I know about the future of AI
um I probably I think you can write that
story it's not inherently unrealistic
how you do it is
um it would be a failed alignment
scenario so someone made AGI at some
point in the 90s and uh maybe they they
were foolish and they gave it the goal
of sort of maintaining that condition
maintaining that Society they thought it
was a decent society and it was a good
fallback and they wouldn't want it to do
anything worse than that
maybe they wanted it to do something
better but that failed for some reason
it fell back to this and now it's just
doing this forever
we're stuck in this life this era that
is something you'd want to fight against
yeah so you're like I hope this AI makes
Humanity better and it's like best I can
do is 90s New York yeah
[Music]
it's our hope that listeners like you
will be inspired by some of the stories
we're exploring in this podcast and
bring your own experiences and insights
to the table and fleshing them out
the process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable
be incredibly powerful whether you're a
creative person looking to produce Rich
works of fiction or have a more
technical focus and are looking to reach
policy makers or the public
our entrance spanned the spectrum and
their hopes for their works are as
diverse as their perspectives and
expertise
I asked Mako what kind of impact he
hoped his work would have on the world
well I have some questions about your
hopes for the Creative Impact of the
world that you made which aspects of
what you've written would you most like
to see taken on by popular media I think
there are definitely things we could do
here
I just think I don't know what they are
yet there are more conversations that
need to be had I think World building
did turn out to be really useful uh like
thinking creatively about some kind of
ambitious things we could do and
depicting them in a way that makes them
visceral and makes them feel real and
possible
that is really useful for sort of
bringing people's thinking up and
letting them imagine and
letting them believe they can build
something big and complicated and new
the question is what should we build
beyond what I've already described to
which I'm not even sure if that's what
we need
yeah
it's great to hear that this world
building exercise was helpful for you in
fleshing things out and imagining this
realistic positive future
I'm curious what you learned about your
own vision of a positive future by doing
the exercise
so I think before I started I couldn't
see any solution to the geopolitical
problem
and so we end up just attending all of
our hopes to corporations doing the
right thing
yeah we're being asked to do this being
offered this bounty I I think I managed
to think of one solution one potential
solution to that problem that
still a very large problem
and there's no guarantee that that
solution will work
yeah but there's hope
yeah that's cool I like how one of your
timeline points had this like this
concept of demon catting and Demon kits
and showing the fearful potential of AIS
comes from the World building
competition and you know as part of what
sets this off is again this kind of like
meta recursive quality
but it's it's really nice
um to hear that that actually was
helpful for you in developing this
Concepts just to have this challenge
posed to you
do you imagine that it would be useful
to have have more thinkers do this kind
of exercise to Source possible solutions
like this absolutely yeah
yeah the challenge of uh exploring sort
of ambitious possibilities and then
asking yourself in detail what would
need to happen in order for this to be
possible
uh if you don't go through that exercise
then you end up with a really narrow
conception of what is possible
what sorts of exploring would you most
like to see other people doing in this
space either for your own creative
development and expression or for the
good of our species I guess
laughs
okay yeah uh
I would love to see more narrative
narrativization or uh illumination of
conflict Dynamics and the like the
geopolitical Dynamics that sort of get
in the way of transparency and
cooperation I think we need to
understand those a lot better because if
you just talk to diplomats they're
they're gonna you so it's not
clear where to look for those and when
you find out how things actually work
it's usually a lot dirtier than you
wanted to believe and
so we need really good depictions of
that we need to give people a sense of
how things really work and then we need
to develop visions of how things could
change
realistic
an ambitious ones because we're gonna
need to change a lot yeah
I mean it occurs to me that some of
these changes will require pretty
diverse forms of expertise like
psychological insights sociological ones
yeah
what what sorts of expertise would you
be most interested in having people
bring to
thinking about a positive future
we need to get really good at talking
about how technology and politics
interacts I think there are going to be
some pretty major transitions soon as
things start to become more transparent
and surveillance starts to become more
common and there's a lot of opportunity
there
I guess I would recommend David brin's
book The the transparent Society
in some countries you're definitely
going to end up with either a police
state at panopticon or a system with
true transparency and that's a huge Fork
those are very different Futures they're
both surveilled but one is accountable
and it's doing what it's supposed to do
and the other is just extremely
repressive I think that kind of
transition could do a lot of good work
or a lot of bad work depending on how it
ends up and of course government has a
huge influence on what kind of research
projects happen
and Military research and weaponization
of Technologies is of course entirely in
the hands of government so yeah the
interaction between technology and
politics is really important we need
people who are good at reasoning about
that and we need to get better at it hmm
well we've covered a tremendous amount
of ground in this conversation
and your world still has plenty of other
interesting details that we could dive
into that we haven't even touched on so
I recommend anyone who wants to learn
more about these ideas to visit
worldbuild.ai
where you can dive into mako's world and
the other winning submissions
and learn more about them and Mako thank
you so much for your time for being on
this podcast for all the labor you put
into this world that you've shared with
us
I really appreciate you joining us
[Music]
this has got you thinking about the
future you can find out more about this
world and explore the ideas contained in
the other worlds at www.worldbuild.ai
we want to hear your thoughts are these
worlds you'd want to live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast you
read all the comments and appreciate
every rating this podcast is produced
and edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute fli is a
non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
if you'd like to get in touch with us or
any of the teams featured on the podcast
to collaborate you can email World build
futureoflife.org
a reminder this podcast explores the
ideas created as part of fli's World
building contest and our hope is that
this series Sparks discussion about the
kinds of Futures we all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
[Music]